人の悪の感情を使ってこの世の支配を目的とする悪の組織悪。彼らを倒すべく決収された小学生のヒーローたち。その名も
[音楽]
小学隊バンカリバンバンバン。主役は君さ。バンバン。正義のためにバンバンバンバン。カレンじゃ。
[拍手]
[音楽]
バンカラジオ。
前回のバンカレンジャーワを見てからだと面白いよ。ここをクリック。
うじ、あいつが悪の組織の親玉だったなんて。チョークが欲しいな。
僕の家金持ちだからチョークたくさん買ったよ。だめだ。遅い。
お前の正体は何だ?
[音楽]
私のやるためんだよ。
何が目的でも悪
僕の家だから何でも買えるんだけどお金じゃ買えないものもあるんだよね。まあ、お金くれないのは辛いけど、元々あいつ影かったし気にすることないよ。
[音楽]
こら、良くないよ。
ま、確かにあいつはもう敵だしな。そういえばさ、昨日の
2世TV
見たなんかめちゃめちゃ台パしてたんだよ。
さ、
おしれえ。あ、始めるぞ。
お、
おい、こら、何学校に持ってきたんだ。忘だ。
ええ、あ、ぼ、僕のその顔聞いた。デブ博士に買ってもらおうねえ。買ってくれるといいな。面白いな、この人。マジにしようと。
[音楽]
[笑い]
いいわね。面白いじゃない?
僕それ食べていい?
準備が大事だからね。
全ては世界を支配するため。くそ。休みはねえし、み噌の在庫はなくなるし。ハチコばっかだよ。あ、なんだこれ。
[拍手]
[音楽]
う、で、博士、新しいスマホ買ってくれないかな?魔人をたくさん倒すから。
だめだよ。こっちもお金カツカツなんだ。
ぶっカ、もう僕食べちゃおう。レアの味噌食べるなよ。
新しい魔人がまれた。行くんだ。バンカレンジャーブル。
今日の2なんか様子がおかしいな。
おい、どこはダーク
2。この憎いこと考えろ。ネガティブになれ。
魔人化した2
によって子供たちは負の感情を出すことになり、その負の感情は悪のアジトにある謎の黒い玉に吸収されていくのであった。
子供たちに負の感情を出させてやる。ブンブンブンブン
やめろ。
2魔人俺らが売してやる。
小学体バラリナぺ
ブンブンハローYouTube
くそブンハローYouTube
しか言えなくなっちまった。
イエロービ攻撃
キのラーメンができました。
くそ攻撃が効かない。どうすりゃいいんだ?に絡まったよ。
でもうまいよ。うまいよ。そうか。分かったぞ。この枕をめんめんべん。
まずい。
今ないと2を太もで挟め。分かったよ。
[拍手]
マッサージ気持ちブ。
あとは布団だ。
ニ金は休まず働いて頑張ってるのにアンチコメントとか味噌金の製造が遅れてるっていうストレスで限界だったんだ。やろう
YouTube。すやスや郎
YouTube。
だから休ませてあげるのが1
番良かったんだ。イエログ
頑張りすぎてもよくない時には休むことも大事だな。俺らが代わりに動画を作ってやるか。
何これ?ブハロYouTubeハロー
Youブハロー
YouTube
世間魔シンがやられてしまいました。
そうだね。でも準備は進められたからよかったよ。
その黒い玉何なの?
君には関係ないことだ。よしよしよしよし。
あら、怖い怖い。
彼らも強くなってるからね。君行ってきなよ。
[音楽]
行ってきます。
はい、皆さん今日はチャックとちまめの木をやります。ちまめをチャックに挟んだ。い、ここの自
でも変な揺れ方だね。
なんかおかしいぞ。
なんじゃこりゃ。
魔人が現れた。急いで行ってくれ。
みんな行くぞ。
デブ魔人は全てを食べ尽くし、人々を恐怖のどん底に落とし入れるのだ。
[音楽]
来たか。バンカレンジャー
行くぞ。お、イエロビーム。鼻くそ攻撃
メロメロビーム。
ま
な、何攻撃が効かないだと。
みんな攻撃が弱すぎるんよ。
レクジャンプ。おお。
ああ。
まゆ、眉ゆう。
あれは本当にデブだね。
え、デブって言うな。なるほど。引いたこじ大会を改しろ。
え、
それでは行きます。大御。よい。スタート。
[拍手]
聞いた。頑張ってます。デブ魔人は
[音楽]
まさかの3秒で完食。
デブバンド勝利。
イエー。たくさん食べれるってすごい。
本当は太ってる自分が嫌なんだ。でもたくさん食べれるってことはすごいことなんだよ。ありがとう。ありがとう。ありがとう。
[音楽]
え、そんなに
たくさん食べちゃう自分が嫌いだったし、悪いの部ではしっぱだったし、こんなに人に認めてもらうことが初めててな。
[拍手]
ならよかったよ。僕を仲間に入れてくれないか?悪い子を倒すために協力するよ。
いいよ。
魔人が仲間になったのか。何か悪い図の情報を教えてくれないか?
[音楽]
そうだね。僕もおしっぱだからあまり情報はもらえなかったんだけど、何か準備をしているみたいなんだ。
準備?
人々の負の感情を集めて何か黒いエネルギーを作ってるみたいなんだ。
これがたまれば恐怖で世界を支配できる。ん?おい、何見てんだ?
[音楽]
ごめんなさい。
みたいなことを言ってたんだ。
[音楽]
世界を支配する黒いエネルギー。なるほど。
2人ともおデブで兄弟みたいだね。
デブじゃない。ぽけだ。
なんだ?悪じ何してるの?早く戻りなよ。
[音楽]
僕はバンカレンジャーと戦うって決めたんだ。
じゃあ切り物だね。ここでおさら苦しい苦しいよ。
[音楽]
ああ。ふう。
お前、あいつは仲間じゃなかったのか。
別に僕に仲間なんかいらないよ。ま、年中でも楽しんでればね。
[音楽]
あ、またこれだわ。
いつまで未来を見ているんだ?早く行ってこい。
どうしたの?余裕がないじゃない?
裏切り物がね。君の能力で早くバンカレを倒してきな。
分かったわ。
はい。ど徳です。人生なんて基本大変。おばく。
先生は人生終わってるからね。
そうなんだ。昨日も立ちんコに負けて夜は地下労働のワイト。また今日も負けた。イエー。
ほら、早く。
おい、遅いぞ。
おい、中に仕事しめ。
そんなんで人生大丈夫ですか?
将来のことなんて気にしてるか。
はい、授業終了。
みんな私の家にチラシが届いてて占い1
時間無料なんだってみんなで行ってみない?い
い。そうだね。
[音楽]
[拍手]
占い占い占い占い占い占い占い占い
お願いします私は未来が見えるの
えすごい
そうねお母さんにたくさん怒られてるわ
お母さん怖いなあんだここはお母さん
ネちゃん宿題しなさいって言ったでしょ。
言って宿題やりなさいって言ったでしょ。
さって言ったでしょ。宿らなさいって言ったでしょ。さて
ななんだこれ。
ふ。これで全員仕留めたわ。未来に怯えて眠りなさい。
占い魔人は未来の辛い現実を見せて負の感情を誘発し、黒い玉に吸収させるのであった。
[音楽]
ちゃんはるちゃん。うわあ。
[拍手]
あ、うんちがいっぱい。うんちがいっぱいだ。僕の太もが細になるんよ。
なんだこれ?臭い。臭い。臭い。現実だったのか。お前。魔人だな。
また占ってあげましょうか。
あなたはまたお母さんに怒られる。
もうとどめをさしていいかしら。お友達だったんでしょ。
ああ。
[音楽]
処理しちゃってカレンジーがいなくなればこの世界を支配できるからね。ここか。え、
あら、先生、あなたも現実にかかりに来たのね。あなたの未来は生徒たちにいじめられてるわ。うわ。
[音楽]
帰れ、帰れ、帰れ、帰れ、帰れ、帰れ、帰れ、帰れ、帰れ。
何?辛い。現実を抜けただと?
こんなもん。一条
あなたの水道とガスが止まるわ。
そんなのとに止まってる。
貯金がゼ。落ちそら借均1000
万だ。ゼロの方が嬉しい。
うう。
未来のことなんて当てにならん。地獄のような今を生きることで全いっぱいなんだぜ。
でも年を取って自分の日美が失われたりしたら辛いじゃないの。
年なんて誰でも取る。今を生きるだけなんだ。
占い魔人は自分の未来の悩みが解決され苦しむのであった。
今がチャンスだ。全員集まれ。
小学スバカレンジャーピ
ーふでお前ら何してんだ?
えっと実はヒーローでして
はあ
やられたか占い魔だが準備はもう終わる。
はい。マシン様
この枠エネルギーを地球に洗った時々を負の感情でコントロールできるんだ。
[音楽]
その後浜先生はデブ博士に認められてバンカレンジャーになったのであった。
俺がヒーローなんてやる。先生がリだ。
それは違うだろ。
あんまりゆっくりしてる時間はなさそうだ。
え、
調べたところ悪のエネルギーがほぼたいつつある世界が制服されてしまうようだ。修行して強くなり悪人を止めるぞ。
おお
バンカレンジャーたちは新たなメンバーを迎えて息を合わせるために修行するのであった。
みんなもう時間がない。丸を倒して世界の平和を守るんだ。このゲートを通ってくれ。
やってやりますか。
さて、準備はできたな。
はい。
これで世界を制服するのだ。
うじ。いや、悪じを止める。
最後に邪魔をしに来たか。
鼻くそ、鼻くそ、鼻くそ。
メロメロピロメロメロメロ
行け。
[拍手]
よし。残念だったな。
[音楽]
俺は無だ。
何こうなったら
小学隊バンカリンダースペシャルビーム。
うわあ。
うわー。ああ、
やったか。惜しいな。だがまだだ。
来。
もう追いつかないよ。
こいつだからメルメロが効かない。
が疲れないよ。
[音楽]
悪じ、お前はなんでこんなことをするんだ?お金で買えないものって何なんだ?おい、うじ、聞いてるのか?友達だよ。友達。僕は昔から天校ばっかで友達ができなかったんだ。
天校生のうんだよ。
[音楽]
お金があればちやほやしてくれるけど、それは友達じゃなくてお金の関係なんだ。
チョークが欲しいな。
僕の家持ちだからチョークたくさん買ったよ。
そんなの違う。俺は友達だと思ってるよ。一緒に勉強したし。
[音楽]
一緒に給食べたし。
一緒に鬼心したし。
[笑い]
たくさんお金もくれたし。
はい。ありがとう。おい、
やっぱりそうだ。やっぱりそうだ。やっぱりそうだ。僕のことお金でしか見てないんだ。もう怒った。もう怒った。うわー。
[音楽]
まずい。俺が食い止めるこい
や根す君、
みんな俺のことは気にするな。世界の平和はバッカレンチャーが守れ。
[音楽]
結果的に世界制服は止められちゃったけど、アンカレンジャー倒したし、あなたの仲間加わったね。
やめて。ああ。ああ。ああ。
[音楽]
残されたら君だけだ。君がこの世界を救うんだ。
歌言うとぼ僕
ちゃちゃちゃちゃちゃよろしく登録よろしく最初はグチネル登録チャンネル登録ま
[音楽]
チャンネル登